there's a lot of roles that I really
wanted that I didn't get the one that
sticks out to me for some reason is I
think it was Deadpool 2 I think I was
shooting Legion at the time as revealed
in an interview with Cosmopolitan Plaza
attempted to take on the role of domino
the ludicrously lucky assassin and ex-
Force member Plaza admitted she wasn't
in the right Zone at the right time for
the potential Gig if only the mutant's
special gift could have bled into
Plaza's audition because as she saw it
she wasn't in the head space for it she
admitted I was really not like in a good
Z Z cuz auditioning you have to be in an
auditioning Zone and I was in a work
Zone that one hurt me and Ryan Reynolds
like what could go wrong we'd be so
great together